what's the first step in writing a
screenplay there's there's there's just
there's an idea and usually what I know
is I know
Beetlejuice for instance the idea was
that I discuss with my partners a
psychedelic ghost comedy we had no idea
what that meant but it rolled off the
tongue right and and and and I usually
have something of an idea like that and
I kind of know the beginning and I kind
of know the end the middle is the great
unknown but but but but it's it's an
instinct an idea and sometimes it's a
character and sometimes it's a situation
but it's very it's very internal at
first and and and yes there's times
where you write an assignment you know
and you're you're you're given an idea
and say translate this into a movie but
in terms of my my own my own writing if
you will my my personal writing it
usually comes from front from just the
most basic kind of idea and a feeling
you know and and it's like and I can't
articulate it very well I'm sorry
because it's hard to articulate but it's
just kind of like again like a situation
in our character that's just kind of
waiting to come out and then you
whatever you whatever your process is
and boy do you need a process and boy do
you need to go to work and boy do you
need to sit down and do it and do the
job of writing and and and you allow
that that character of that situation to
just start growing and sort start coming
you know leaving your fingers on to the
digital page these days you know on your
computer and then it grows and expands
that takes on life and and you know I
there's of course and this is that this
is every writers choice there's a lot of
talk about backstory always you know
like like tell it you know where did
your character go to school how you know
what what was his or her mommy like and
all of that I've never written a
backstory in my life never but if you
ask me to tell me the backstory of one
of my characters I could I'd kind of be
making it up as I went along but the
feelings would be true because I feel I
I feel the characters and I and I feel
like they need to come out and I feel
like they need to be given a voice and
and that's just that that that's that's
what writing is to me a an idea or a
character or situation or an emotion or
a feeling that that you somehow have to
put into the world and it's hard to
articulate and I feel like I'm talking
in circles but I but it's it just it's
almost hard not to because it's so it's
so ephemeral in the beginning you know I
I hope that makes some version sense it
does in ini so the middle it sounds like
is undetermined but you know and ending
when you start to I kind of knowing
anything I kind of know anything that
that can all change but people get very
scared of the middle but for me that's
when it gets fun because it's so
challenging and you so get to what you
know in the screenplay if you think of a
screenplay is 110 120 pages you get to
page 60 and you go oh my god I'm only
halfway there what happens next
but but something will happen and and I
and that's exhilarating and it's
exhilarating to go to bed completely
sure
that you will never figure out what's
going to happen next and wake up with
the answer and that and and and it's you
know it's it's a it's it's a daily
challenge but it's a it's so it feel it
feels so good to realize that that next
scene will be there if you keep working
at it there's there's it's the best
feeling in the world other than
finishing and then finishing it's like
the first draft no matter what shape
it's in is like brilliant I mean that's
just I always get tears in my eyes when
I finish a first draft because I feel
like I'm saying goodbye to a group of
people that I'd been on this journey
with and and there's a there's a very
emotional side to it
and then you know then you become the
craftsman and time for a second draft
and all of that but it's it's an it's an
emotional journey and to do that day
after day it's it's incredibly rewarding
I got the best job in the world so let's
say you're sixty pages in yeah and now
you're kind of like what do I do next
so keeping in the vein of not waiting
for inspiration yeah and and you're
treating this as a job it's like working
in a bank yeah so what's happening let's
suppose it's 9:00 a.m. Monday morning
you're 60 pages in you've got the cup of
coffee and you're there and you I will
go back I will never go back to the
beginning because that is a death trap I
know what I'll do I'll go back and
rewrite the first 60 pages and then I'm
not going to rewrite the first 60 pages
again and again I'll go back and read a
couple of pages and and maybe do some
cosmetic stuff just to get you know just
to put myself back into the zone of the
story and then you just and then I just
start writing and they may not be good
ideas there may be my drafts are always
30 pages too long when I finished the
first job because I'm telling the story
to myself uh but I I forget who it was
I'm going to say Oscar Wilde I'm gonna
say son famous writer said just sit down
and start typing your name over and over
even Oscar Wilde made the Prix
typewriter I bet but the you understand
the point start typing your name start
doing anything with your fingers and I
and again it's it's like where that
comes from
and where that next scene comes from
it's there it is there and if you put
yourself in a position to find it you
will find it and I might spend the day
writing ten basically bad pages but
there will be one page of truth in it
and one one moment that will move the
story forward and and Stephen King talks
about this really brilliantly and he I
have questions about outlining and I'm
not here to have an outline debate he's
scathing about outlining if you've ever
read his book on writing great probably
the best book I'm writing ever written
into my mind but he always says it's
what happens next it's what happens next
what happens the next one happens next
and you know if I were to reach across
the room here and and steal your pate
your notes from you there would be a
response yeah that or if I were to kick
the camera over today I'm done with this
interview there would be a response
right and then it's what happens next do
you jump on me and I could say give me
my notes back you jerk to you I mean and
it's really that it kind of gets it and
if you just look at it like that that
that and you look at it like like
whatever whatever you made
happen something has to happen next and
that's what happens next what happens
next what happens next what happens next
that what happens next will come and it
may not come easily and there may be a
lot of like I said bad what happens next
before you right find the right what
happens next but it'll come and it's it
and it's a magical process
I mean magical in the sense that that
it's almost unexplainable and it's why
and it's why there's so many
screenwriting programs and apps and and
and all of these things out there to
kind of tell you that they can tell you
what happens next
but they can't tell you what happens
next only you can tell you what happens
next and I look at as a moment-by-moment
process and I put these characters in a
situation and it's often diabolical and
it's often otherworldly and they've got
to get themselves either deeper into it
or get the hell out of it and that's the
journey and it's moment by moment and
it's and it's it's sort of literally
second-by-second if you think about it
you know movies move forward in a linear
fashion and it's just in and it's just
tracking that and and and putting your
character and and when it really gets
fun is when you put your character in
the most difficult out that that that is
probably the an illustration that I use
about this all the time
you